hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra just saw and today I
went and saw lego movie - the second one
or something the lego movie 2 the second
part there we go
got this nice collectible ticket and I
will promptly throw away such a waste
things like this such a waste
I don't know do people look like this
who wants this oh it's the 490th of 500
tickets though it's pretty close to the
cutoff and now that I know that I
actually do want it I watched the first
lego movie for Tamra's never seen and
thought it was adorable and a really
really really quality kids movie and I
was excited about this I feel like it
wasn't hyped as much as I thought it
might have been the first was such a
phenomenon and people just went crazy
about it I didn't see it until way later
hence Tara's never seen and people could
not believe that I missed it make sure
sure sure yeah yeah yeah yeah you
haven't seen Citizen Kane
you you ever see the lego movie so I was
really excited for this and I think it
was incredibly well done there's a few
things that I had a issue with but I
mean should even say issue it's more
just sitting there being like well I
really really enjoy this what can I talk
about might amber just subs but I think
it was a little long I keep saying that
my last like five episodes I've been
like it was like a little long I do I
think it's a little long comparatively
to the last one and I do think that
there weren't as many laugh out loud
jokes but I still did laugh out loud and
I still really enjoyed the comedy though
I think it was a little not off a little
less zingy than the first and that's the
word I'm sticking with zingy I loved the
music
I loved the villain who we think is the
villain at first turns out to not be the
villain I love how self-aware they are
with certain things
we Chris Pratt's character something
vest danger vest baby and I would say
that the biggest laughs and the best
comedy for me and my favorite scenes
outside of the music are the ones where
there's a ton of characters and they're
making jokes about all the characters
like they call out Val Kilmer's lips at
one point with Batman he's got some
great lips that were like they call out
Sheryl Swoopes and they call out oh
there's a lot of characters that come
out I think that's the most exciting
part and the most funny part to me like
younger children probably aren't gonna
know who Sheryl Swoopes is she's the
famous basketball player and so they
like say it you're so right Sheryl
Swoopes the famous basketball player and
I think that's really funny there's also
some collabs to older bands and older
movies one that particularly made me
laugh out loud and theater you are Back
to the Future Inc what's Back to the
Future it's a movie that older kids get
to watch and then they just completely
go back into the story really really
really funny I loved that because I've
seen Back to the Future I don't know if
you guys know this but and see that
movie is that it's pretty cool the movie
is a direct sequel from the first in the
first the kid blood Bruce Willis's Bruce
Willis is in this and he's great um Will
Ferrell's Bruce Moe's Will Ferrell's son
finds all of his Legos and starts
playing with him and he's like well now
that you're allowed to do it we're gonna
have to let your sister do it and that's
where it starts where the sister and
brother are colliding and it's kind of
like a fight between this cool Mad Max
II Lego world and then all this adorable
princess unicorn Kitty Lego world and
it's kind of the merging of the two
throughout the film I really liked the
message at the end it's that the younger
toys are looking up to the the older
toys and it's the younger sisters
looking up to the older brother and I
also got that like all of the sisters
Legos for the most part are like the
newer generation
and most of his or the older generation
and I kind of got like a sense of Lego
being like oh yeah well we're kind of
pulling from the older generation too
and I don't know there's a lot of it was
really sweet I liked it a lot if you
haven't seen the movie you won't know
what this means but there's a lot of
cats in the gritty part of the Lego
world that they're in and I just wrote
down in the middle of the film
Ike is Thaksin toes forwards but what a
sentence that I never thought I'd say I
kiss Thaksin toes so there's some really
good lines in the movie that had me
laughing or at least giggling or at
least acknowledging that they were funny
a great line is your couch in for an
ouch in I would love that and I will
start saying it I'm couching for an ouch
him I like Chris Pratt as a voice actor
I like how I was again I keep saying
this was self-aware they were of him he
voices two characters if you didn't know
the second character that he voices is
like a raptor trainer and I think the
Raptors were really funny at some point
they yell out best buddies that's pretty
hilarious they talk about him having
chiseled features under previous
baby-fat they talk about a lot of the
different projects that he's been a part
of and it's it's pretty well done it's
it's super self-aware I will say the two
main characters in it right and wild
style I'm it's Chris Pratt and wild
south I think we're the most boring of
them all I don't know I didn't feel that
way in the first but I definitely felt
that here that I just wasn't super
interested in the wild style goes
through this whole thing or she's like
I'm not actually as tough as I lead on
to be my head is actually all blue and
it's like okay that I don't know it just
didn't do it for me super much maybe
that's where things got long where we
were just focusing mainly on them
because the side characters all ruled
and they were really funny and I think
those moments whereas just them didn't
really work for me cuz I also just don't
think they're a great couple and at the
end
not really said that there are a couple
there like do you want to be super
special best friends and he's like yeah
for life okay
weren't they definitely a couple in the
first and then now they're kind of
retreating into super special best
friends because that's not what I call
my significant other which is Ike just
kidding that's disgusting okay Batman
goes off on this whole rant about
different Batman's and and that our lead
tip Tiffany Haddish Haddish Tiffany I
don't know she was phenomenal in this my
definite favorite character such a cool
animation style - she keeps transforming
she's a Lego obviously and her and
Batman have this song together it's
something like I'm just not into Gotham
City guys it's so cute he's talking
about how like he's way better than
Superman and she's like well I didn't
even like you when you were Christian
Bale and he's like well what about these
Val Kilmer lips and George Clooney looks
and it's it's pretty great Batman is it
permanent bat chiller Ruth Bader
Ginsburg is in this president business
doesn't fix anything and then pills
golfing pursuit there's some fun thanks
Maya Rudolph was in it as the mother I
don't remember her being in the first I
think it was just Will Ferrell as the
father I'm not mistaken I love Maya
Rudolph so it was really fun to see her
she steps on a Lego I love that they did
that because again I don't think they
did that in the first and that's such a
big thing with Legos stepping on them
she's like I'm close to childbirth here
it's pretty work it's pretty on par here
with childbirth hilarious I think the
last hour is better than the first 50
minutes of the movie for sure it
definitely ramps up the first bitches it
drags a bit there's a lot of Emmet's
again and wild style Lucy right it's
just a fun funny well-written movie that
could have had some stuff shaved off is
it as good as the first I think so are
there moments of it being a little dull
it didn't change my life but I would
absolutely recommend it if not for the
music alone it's really really well done
there's one song called this is always
gonna be stuck in your head or something
and I I never do this but I recorded
that little chunk of excited that I was
gonna forget it and I did forget it
this song really gets stuck inside joke
this song really get stuck inside your
head
it's worth it I'm glad I recorded it I
think my new system of hairflip ratings
is gonna be a little little
lackadaisical I think I might get give
things too high up scores where we give
this an 8 out of 10 hair flips and I
stand by it
over all the kids in my theater we're
really enjoying it there weren't a ton
but I mean I did see it at 11:30 a.m. on
a Friday so it's to be expected I know
that I enjoy everything but I really
enjoyed this movie go see it it's funny
it's fun and teaches some good lessons
and who though could have thought that
it would come from Legos a giant movie
of commercials thank you so much for
watching I will see you all next week
bye tops and toes where are you
[Music]